something that i heard i think in 2004
was that magnus had declined to work
with gary kasparov and at that time i
was thinking wow
that's an incredibly bold decision
2005 2005 okay apologies yeah and
i still remember the shock that i felt
and i thought wow
you know how can a child refuse that and
then i thought hang on a second
this takes guts this takes confidence so
i mean what was the strategy for
developing magnus as a player
well
basically this is in line with
what i
introduced about
letting him be in charge of the process
and trying to
to kind of guard him from
from
people around who wanted to influence
him
because i told people already when he
was 10 11 12 and said oh no no it's he's
just a hobby he's
he's having fun uh
i'll support him but
he'll decide because already when he was
12 or 13 people start saying well what
if he wants to stop playing chess yeah
then he'll stop playing chess and you're
cool with that yeah of course that is
come on yeah
he's putting in all the work he's
all the dedication it's his
his game basically and
when we had the session with kasparov
that was very interesting
over christmas 2004
very interesting and we also had a
session in moscow in the spring but then
magnus got some homework that he didn't
really like and then he decided no no i
don't want to do that so basically it's
a bit more nuanced than the story you
might ever heard and i remember thinking
at the time that
well
turning down cooperation with kasparov
all-time great
doesn't sound like a good idea but again
it's his hobby so i didn't even discuss
it with him i basically it was
he said he didn't want to do okay fine
that's that's it and that that's
fortunately a lesson i had learned
already yeah uh uh once or twice really
but no no no this is uh
we have to trust him but because it's
it's his yeah
it's not ours it's his
and he seems to even know what he's
doing anyway
so i mean it just took
one and a half years after
this
[Music]
training camp with kasparov that
one of his trainers
met me at the tall memorial i think even
a half years later and
i said well man you still plays a lot
maybe you should and he said no no it's
okay i we
have recognized that magnus has this
unique ability to learn
from preparing for
and playing a game and then
immediately digesting
experience at the board that day so that
he's ready to move on in a way so they
kind of
admitted that
yeah this seems to work for magnus he's
uh he's doing fine because they had been
a bit critical about playing so much and
not studying so much and
maybe not calculating precisely always
and
[Music]
unfortunately i kept my hands
set on my hands and
didn't try to influence him